one of your first acting jobs is
actually dubbing cartoons not dubbing
cartoons but dubbing foreign films I
mean when I was growing up on TV they
would have these kind of you know
gladiator films or like Speed Racer
cartoons right Speed Racer and and so I
got a job
dubbing voices in foreign films and if
you don't know what dubbing is it's a
and we do an American TV and mu and
movies too if the sound is bad you've
got to go into a studio and then redo
the sentence like for instance okay
let's let's do it now okay let's do okay
so sorry alright so now that just say
this line say the line Melvin I have to
devein the shrimp just say it
Melvin I have to devein the shrimp right
okay now I heard a sound so we have to
take that out you have to my mouth yeah
but it's in another language so I have
to find a line to fit the same kind of
mouth flaps okay but I have to put in a
line that's germane to whatever film I'm
I'm trying to so like if I'm gonna mouth
that say Melvin what do you would you
have to say Melvin I have to devein the
shrimp okay so now don't the only voice
now be be be there's a monster
[Laughter]
listen you're a terrible beeper
approximate your car you know that's
amazingly hard let's do it again can't
look at you look at me there's a monster
in the living room I walked in and
watched my daughter she's five and I let
her just like pick something on Netflix
you know whatever I was doing something
and all this tonight I'm like why are
they speaking Spanish yeah she watches
things that are from spanner but they'll
try and do them in English like half the
episode is English they do that a lot
still yes yeah part of the problem is
that you know in in different languages
there's different Cadence's yeah rhythm
isn't so that's why if you watch a lot
of old movies you'll hear people talking
like this over there because fit in
dialogue into foreign mouth flapping oh
my god that's hard and hard not to laugh
obviously that's 11 hmm I know I know
you know I should just steer clear
forget it I feel like I should doing it
too much already
yeah subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going